[音楽]
goo 2
ああああああ
はっはっは
この数字は
2013年に
自ら
自分の栄誉賞
とした自殺をした
日本に戻っです
今少子高齢化ねー
希望は
日本はまだまだ
実際は言われているにも関わらず
どんどん中学生は命を起こしてしまいます
決勝の発表によれば東日本大震災デー
命を落とした従来の男女の数は約340
あの輸送の大災害等
ほとんど同じ数の子供たちがいい
自らの手で命をはっぴーそれがこの系の現状です
ただその一方で同じタイミングで
とてもキラキラしていて
重い継続をしていて周りプラスの影響を与えている子供たちもいるんです
もしかしたら皆さんあまりにもこのような子どもたちがいたのではないでしょうか
シェイク
命命を絶つ子供子キラキラと輝く子供
そのサワー一体何なのでしょうか
僕はこの3増えるのかメルベル
教育という選択をします
この差を埋められるが教育です
皆さん
教育に対してどれくらい可能性を感じていますか
教育へ先ほどの差を埋められるぞ
信じていましたーーー
僕は希望このがねぇ
教育が持つ力を証明します
そもそも皆さん
教育が大切だと思っていますか大切だと曲がってあげてください
ありがとうございますでは今のこの日本の教育に対して少し書いた方がいいところが
あるんじゃないからこの方は
てあげます
ありがとうございます
ではお子さんお持ちの方それから将来お子さんを持つである皆さん
このままの上位9だったらちょっと不安だなぁと感じているか立ってありください
ありがとうございます
僕も皆さんと同じく教育に対して少し不安の
なんかちょっと違うぜ疑問を抱いていました
そして僕はこの教育を買いたい
この教育を変えなきゃいけないと思います
じゃあなぜそう思ったのか
それは僕のパパにあります
僕は幼いときに
要するになりこうして父親湯引き取られ父と祖母顔あれの4人で暮らしていました
我が家の書けばとにかく中でしたっ
なので僕は好きなことを好きなだけやっても大丈夫でした
もちろん
a ギア挨拶に対しては厳しかったですね
ただ僕が入りたいことに対しては
いつでも応援してくれるしそれに対して何かくれたというような家庭ではない
そんな過程でそうしました
だからボケはもしかしたら他の人よりもわがままかもしれないしまだ強いかもしれませ
ん
その政策が影響して僕は
人から一つの価値観に当てはめられたらいい
束縛をされることをとっても着られますん
それが原因ゲー
食べた気いろんな人と衝突をしてしまいました
その衝突する相手バー時は
お空にあってメール人に会っても始め買ってしまう
そんな少年でした
そして度ため僕は社会が持つ
何か決まりきった体大臣であったりとか
価値観を押しつけるような風習に
時々フェスタを感じていました
自分とた過去の違いにプレッシャーを感じていましたん
例えば僕は小中学生の時に1と4市が大きく変わっていました
それをからかわれたりいろいろや各言われることがあって実質いたと思います
はたまた中高生なった時は僕は
意見や考え方が周りと少し違っていました
それでなかなか周りなかなかに馴染めてみたいときコメ付いたり
ちょっと入ったような存在です
英語国は
それでや指苦しいぴ続けるということがなかったんです
なぜなら中なくコーク架空ところに御苦労やは
自分は自分他人はか中たりがたり
あなたは何かと言ってくれたからです
だから時はそうか自分の自分のままでいいなと思ってきていました
ん
そんな僕は自分の好きなことにとてもとてもまっすぐです
小学校の時はカードゲームが大好きで大好きで大好きで仕方なくて
卒業文集にその cars ゲーム6度を書いちゃうくらいスでした
はたまた中学生の時は卓球に没頭して
2なた母
1日3時間も4時間も部活にも帰って選ぶ中よりも通ってひたすら卓球をやっていまし
た
はたまた高校生の時はテレビドラマにハマって1週間に何十本を見る存在から症例でし
そして僕だー
大学生になったときに
人生一番好きなものでありません
それが教育の仕事です
予備校でアルバイトをしていてたくさんの努力する子供たちを見ました
ん
僕はそんな子どもたちが
変わる瞬間 before があったりなる瞬間がとても好きで
努力する姿を応援するがすごくすごく好きでした
だから僕は自主的に注意メーカーの何パターンも働いたりしましたん
でもそれが楽しくでとてもやりがいが感じながら日々教育の仕事にあたっていたんです
ね
ただ100%ではなかったんです
自由を頃に束縛を嫌う固定の価値化も切らボケは
教育にある
一つのことがどうしても納得いかなかっ
それがあ
今の教育のスタイルシステムです
もちろん国分制度クリッカー社債を提供することはとてもとても大切ですそれ自体を
否定するわけではありません
でも皆さん考えてみてください
国語と政策とれた社会のケースだけで人を判断していいでしょうか
併殺がフェイクはテストの点数が低いのは熱湯せいでしょうか
襲っている
マグシートを塗りつぶす
ここに夢は見伝えるでしょうか
時はこういった点数に表れないこと
係数に現れない個性とかその頃やりたいこととか
その後自身のこととかもっとそういったものを伸ばしてあげるべきなのではないかと
思っていました
多くの人が自分のか人が違っていることに対して悩むんです
でもよく考えてみてください一人一人違うです
この中で会場の中で自分を髪の毛が同じもうする人を探すことができますか
自分と今まで食べてきたものがヒ素出会ってきた人がいそう
歩んできた道のりの個数が一緒だという人はいますか
一人一人違うんです通学いていいんです
2-かかわらず大多数の人が持っている価値観を植え付けてしまうことで少数派の人は
いつも悩みます
一つの物差しで測るから
そうする話したやその物差しで測られる人はどんどんくるしてみます
一つの価値観を当てはめてつらい思いをしている人もいます
そしておそらく大多数派の人の中にも自分の個性はなんだろうと悩んでいる人もいると
思います
個性を認識することができない自分の補正をが生んだとか分からない
そしてその個性を認め合える環境がない
これが
いじめ自殺の
1いいなと思っています
であるのであれば僕は併殺であっていたら形相のもちろんじゃなく個性を伸ばす教育を
したい
人々が個性を認識出来てそして個性を認めが高め合う者かなと出会う場所を作っていき
たい
そういった空間を作れるのが
教育なんです
だから僕は
株式会社 dig を2015年1月しっかりつくりました
bid が
ba のリーの略です
そしてプロビーバーいいでは一歩一歩階段を登るように夢と実現しているようみんなで
努力しちゃうことを大切にしています
この日座員が行ってサービスが
若者向けのスクール時のハード暮らしというようなものです
このサードクラスにはもっとがあります
それが
道着車
レーストライというと思います
このサード+を通して子どもたちを始めてプレゼンテーションやリーダーシップ
はたまたさまざまなことを学びます
新しいことで挑戦する時多くの人ができない家を探してしまうんです
そしてやりません
でも僕らはそんなできないよ
追っ払ってとりあえずやってみようよと声をかけます
できない理由をひっくり返した先にはできるかもしれない方法がるっていう
この3クラスでは違う価値観を創造主アウト
そしてコミュニケーションを大切にしています
だから講師1人から学ぶのではなく仲間から友達から先輩から後輩から学ぶ9感を大切
にしています
だからここで学べることは
一般の図書館でん
見れるような本屋さんで売っているような教科書に書いてあることだけではないんです
一人一人の仲間から仲間が持っている kk も自分の学びとして得ることができる
そして一人一人の価値観を大切にしちゃうことができるんです
そしてこの中でボケが大切にしているコンテンツがあります
それが
夢です
生徒たちは
8分間のプレゼンテーションを夢ラペル系と思います
皆さん
今すぐ8分日目に見えてるじゃん押して下さいと言われてできますか
この課題に対して
子どもたちは学生たちがとてもとても悩みます
格好します
なぜなら自分の夢は自分の心の中にしかないからです
でも
なんとか見つけ出そうなんとか考えようと思って中の粉相談し合ってたかみ合っていく
んです
その過程の中で
この子たちはひとまわりもふたまわりの成長していくんです
そして
自分の個性なんだろう自分のやりたいことは何だろうと思いその熱意のこもった油冷前
をしてその行く冷泉を聞いた仲間たちと心と心でつながりあるんです
そういう欲は教育の力だと思っています
僕は
教育の仕事を通してたくさんのビフォーのあったを見てきました
例えば
自信がなくて人前で話すのが苦手だったけども
100人の前で話して道具をと堂々と話せるようになればっ
自分は補正なんてない人入っていて自分の将来どんなことをやりたいのか分からないと
悩んでいたとが夢が見つかってその夢に向かって思い切り努力する姿を見てきました
またまたぁ
友達が少ないんです友達がいなんですと言っていた子がたくさんの仲間に囲まれて
その仲間の中で中心人物くなってリスペクトされている姿を見ました
教育をとしてさまざまなビフォーとアフターが見れるんです
への僕は教育の一番の感動するポイントは
1番の魅力は
ビフォーとアフターん間にあるプロセスを見えるところだと思います
驚異計算されるものはプロプロセスを見ることができます
このプロセスをみる上から一人一人が可能するんです
でも
before が after いいなるためには
必ず
捉えが必要なんです
だから僕はゾンビ車ジャス暗い道3歳
熱捉えという言葉を大切にしています
もしかしたら一人ではできないこともみんなと一緒ならできるかもしれません
僕は企業先祖キー
正直ふなめしだ
いつかは経営者になりたいと思っていた5日教育のことをやりたいと思っていた
でも正直不安でいっぱいでした
でもそんな僕にレースとライブ行ってくれる人がいました
そして今僕は一人じゃなくて多くの仲間と仕事をしています
その原体験その一番大切になっていたところがこれこの木をつけてくれたのが
家族からの花火でありそして沢山の仲間からの学びなんです
そして
僕自身の夢が僕をここまで連れてきてくれました
ん
だから僕は個性を尊重し合いその個性が
いろんな人に食べられていろんなことができる
そんな空間をつくりたいです
そしてその先にはたくさんの映画を上がっていると思う
教育を通して僕はたくさんのカンヌにで行ってきました
ん
ただこの感動に出会えるのは
試しのか dire です
僕は一人市が教育者だと思っています
そして皆さん一人一人が人生という皆さんにしかない今日2日そう思っていると思い
ます
この教科書の中には皆さんが調整してきたことをやってきたところマナーにしたことが
たくさん入っています
そしてこの教科書が
どんどんどんどん
更新されていきます
であるのであれば
皆さんは
この教科書に
どんなことを書き込みたいですか
皆さんがどんな調整をしたいですか
僕がここにいるデイ全ての方にも個性を認識してそして
自分のその個性を認めざる社会そして離島やてくれる仲間と出会ってほしいと思ってい
ます
もしかしたら皆さんの中には
ああ自分だって自信がない人を持っている方がいるかもしれません
でも僕はそういう皆さんに対しても是非やってほしいと
ぜひトライしてみてほしいとそういう常備したい
で伝えという言葉をかけます
もしかしたら
ここにいる学生の中には
千鶴をせってなんだろう自分の将来経済ことが分からないと悩んでいる人もいるかも
しれません
でもそういう人たちと僕はユリのされたいです
またまたこれからの教育に対してクラウドパリティた方もいらっしゃるでしょう
でもそんな風なを取り除きたいそれが僕がダサいそれが僕が成し遂げタイプなんです
そしてぜひ皆さん
皆さんが挑戦してきたとそれが書かれている教科書の内容を周りの人にシェアしてみて
ください
皆さんの教科書に書かれている一つ一つのことがまわりの人
生まれの子供たちの夢に何かもしれないです
皆さんの初戦はそれだけ価値があるんです
たときはあ
一歩を踏み出そうとしているあなたに
素晴らしい社会を共に創る仲間である
皆さん
これからもがんばっていきたい
そして
黒子ん教科書2体である
一番大切な言葉を
皆さんにとって
この訂正を終わりたいと思います
ゾンビ車
レース前
同3差
ですねー
ありがとうございました
はぁ
ございません